reject nation we have made it to the
penultimate episode of season two of
king dome
only one more after this and then we're
done queen
i'm in your league now i support you
team queen team queen all the way guys
bite into that like button if you
haven't done so already helps out the
channel subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction to the finale is officially
up on the channel should be a week from
today and uh yeah a full-length watch
alongside sync up with the time code for
a kingdom or over at our patreon page
become a superhero jack today by
checking all we got to offer over there
lastly the boys at prepper thanks for
helping us out with these highlights you
guys are good people good people
beautiful men let's get into it
it's just like boba fett and the
gamoreans don't exclude people from your
commentary john in the star wars
[Music]
[Music]
yo
son of a [ __ ] let's get messy as if it
weren't already messy
it's a trap
don't open dead inside
[Music]
rise the most righteous moment
[Music]
we're the chain gang
that's right the original changing
and double executions today
yeah this is
mortifying man
come on tough guy
oh man you made the right choice the
right time
right moment
[Laughter]
oh
dude he's gonna have a powerful ally
over here right now
[Music]
[Music]
you are twisted
rise up
[Laughter]
we go to
[Laughter]
you have proven you are different than
the church
[Music]
[Laughter]
the queen's going to have some insane
martial arts skills
and some kind of resident evil bio
creature
just following orders
take it over
just kind of like a horde of zombies
upper sleeves
just gonna like unleash them
oh what a shot yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh she got dressed for the occasion
paint me
masonry
don't do it they're going to do it they
are going to do it open the vault
although it would be pretty exciting to
see how this goes
unleash the zombies
oh
yeah
oh
yeah
that went to [ __ ] real fast for her
so who wants to open up the next cage
what was the plan exactly
if i let them go they won't hurt me yeah
i'm on their side yeah i'm the good guy
here they're free
where is she she gonna pop up
so much for studying them
oh no it's begun
no royal seals today
we always knew this day would come
[Music]
that's where it all started
[Music]
cool
[Laughter]
oh
what a horrible death
double the pain got murdered and eaten
somehow she'll solve all this
[Laughter]
so much amazing tracking shots here
filmmaking is top notch
i just got i just got it back
the chain gang just got back we just
wiped him out
anything guys
oh yeah
oh this is [ __ ] just keep multiplying
what a mess
everybody grab a weapon jesus
okay for the heads
damn dude who are you
queen
[Laughter]
diabolical
gotta give her credit
jeez
nice
[Music]
oh
i'm sure this happens in a lot of zombie
apocalypses yeah
ah
oh no
they can smell the [ __ ]
go into the [ __ ]
oh
no my guy
ah i choose death wow
oh
epic like the raid now
yes wow
no he just
he just grew up here
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh bad
that is some sam raimi [ __ ] if i've ever
seen it
god damn these like tracking shots are
insane i know and then the
choreography to them yeah every shot is
like moving
save our history
[Music]
come on hack and slash my guy come on
yes there we go
[Music]
still on it
[Laughter]
oh dude that tug [ __ ] was that was not
cool
that was disgusting
it's not cool
it's so stretchy
should have stayed downstairs man
oh
my man needs a ice bath
oh nope
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
live to fight another day
wow
holy moses
[Laughter]
sinister it's a murder this is a crazy
disarray disgusting
queen
[Music]
dope
dope that's definitely their best uh
it's gotta be their best um like just
pure zombie driven
oh yeah episode yeah
yeah there's so many like
nods to classic zombie movie moments but
in their perfect kingdom style i always
say man
the characters and politics
ruin the show
yep
just take away from the cornucopia of
violence that we could be enjoying yeah
and we would never grow numb into it
don't temper that stuff out just give us
more just give us more yeah it doesn't
it's not effective because of the fact
that we're watching characters and story
unfold before we get into
you know catastrophic moments
with zombies that's not what
no it's pure violence is all you need
it's not about the allegorical content
of what the zombies represent and you
know how i know i don't even get what
alligators have to do with it yeah see
people keep saying that i'm like what is
this nature documentary jesus
did not think it was going to escalate
like that nope because they've uh they
haven't really been doing like
full-blown zombie horde attacks lately
yeah it's been mainly the politics and
you know the drama surrounding it
but it's so clever when you see the full
scope of it what it builds to because
you know it's like the last episode
establishes the queen you know she takes
out her dad yeah he seemed like the
ultimate villain
and it's like all right what's she going
to do that's really all that bad
that's what's her evil threatening plan
she can't be smarter than him but she
could be
crazy-ass much crazier yeah
back
a
she could be much crazier oh damn i mean
you should kill your own dad to keep
that throne and keep the power
it's like what else would you do yeah so
it did such a good job because it's like
building up the momentum of like
changing the boys
back home they're taking the throw we're
flipping allegiances yeah we're building
our numbers everyone's like i'm loyal to
you royal highness truth is out i'm on
your side i love you i've always been on
your side you know that's why everyone's
behaving they're literally just it's so
great because it starts from where they
were hiding to then just them marching
through until they get to the palace
gates to meet her
and then it just goes to [ __ ]
right away turns around and then the way
that was executed because i was like it
was such a constant build with the way
it was shot like the tension of it like
all right even though
it seems like every like 10 steps this
guy takes it's a positive outcome right
like it's jake's walking through
it's like 10 minutes of that but then by
the time they get and when they have the
queen cornered you're like what's she
going to do there's no there's nothing
she can do she's just a lady in a chair
with a baby yeah
okay it's a nice outfit yeah and uh so i
guess it was asking to you know
um sending for the
see the signature for the seal and all
that
that's what
um
uh
alerted the
crazy other woman
literary zombies
we're just ready to unleash havoc at any
moment yeah yeah because the way i love
the way it was shot because every it was
constantly moving the camera and in like
smooth fashion and like long long
tracking shots is what they kept doing
like it was they didn't do like a wonder
but there was
there was just like like they really
know how to amplify the tension with
yeah like the amount of just following
yeah almost those perspective-esque even
if they're very smooth still that
perspective like you're really in the
moment but you're also panning around to
these really beautiful composite like
composition is the word that keeps
coming to my mind with this show in
particular because yeah there's so many
subtle flourishes that yeah like i was
you were pointing out like man this
really long tracking shot of them like
marching in but also then they start to
throw in this subtle crush zoom and i'm
like wow like this of all shows out
there must be so heavily storyboarded
and so you know yeah it's free
visualized and and compo like you know
because
you like when you're learning about
directing or anything it becomes clear
that yeah everyone's got a different
style and some people are really like on
set i figure out the shots and you can
tell that and this seems like something
where yeah it's like this must have been
250 percent composed before they stepped
onto the set
generally feels that way with the show
well most certainly with their action
scenes absolutely uh you know but this
whole episode felt that way
it was like you were watching an action
scene even in the just the dialogue
exchanges of just building up that
suspense yeah so by the time you get to
all the crazy violence it just
it brings you back like there's been
enough zombie attacks to the point where
you're like you know fully panicking
when it happens but then this brought
you to that stage though about it
brought you back into it because it's
been a while since you've been around
such a large zombie horse it's like the
first episode of the season yeah then to
get to this point and where you're like
we don't have as many people who know
how to do this and they're just [ __ ]
multiplying now because they're trapped
in here and everyone they sink their
teeth into comes back
so it's just getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and perfect tension driver
yeah so it really does feel like the
odds are stacked against them and and i
love the collapse of it it's just like
ching's here
it's time to reclaim that throne and oh
no oh no it's got is i love hit the
eject button yeah i love the magic and
the queen is so goddamn cold-hearted i
love it if i can have it nobody cares
she's like comforting her baby and she's
just willing to die yeah she's willing
to die it's it's it's it's uh i think
she's great i think she's awesome yeah
100 and i mean i love you i love the way
that they have honed in on that classic
zombie theme but made it feel really
alive across these two seasons of like
part of it is watching the spread and
then the containment almost to the point
of having it under control and yeah
spread again in such a
in the first part of the show we saw it
in such a big way across the country and
now we see it just in this one little
compound and it's a great bookend i feel
like oh absolutely and uh and yeah to
see so many of the characters who have
made it you know even if uh
you know there's a broad ensemble so we
haven't spent like the most intimate
time with everybody but i i was you know
kind of excited seeing all these
different people you know getting their
second shot at you know proving
themselves to prince chang or getting
the redemption [ __ ] coward guy coward
guy for sure though finally finally i
finally grew up god damn backbone yeah
forever jesus christ decided not to kill
some weeping children because when i got
to the point where they got like you
know i'm over there like we were saying
in the last couple episodes like yeah
i'm over this guy i like it's i don't i
don't really root for you you just kind
of pissed me off now yeah and then he
finally he finally makes the choice and
i'm like you look god that you made that
choice
yeah exactly well him and uh and like
the the minister of war guy like the
really intense guy who almost got
executed and it was like really silent
face when you know everyone was about to
like i it was cool to see him get some
like badass points redemption to
our buddy who's been on the council
who you know has been skeptical why did
the guy yeah kill himself though why did
he do that i mean was he bit already uh
that was that was what i guessed he just
looked like he was in such bad shape but
i was like i
it seems like
we saw the other guy you know like
spear himself through and like make it
so i thought
that's what i thought he was trying to
do yeah but i didn't get
why i didn't see him get bit unless i
met there was so much happening
i might have missed it because i was
like no one's helping him hold this door
i know a dog wants to get close
everyone's like everyone's wondering
what we're wondering was he bit i don't
know bleeding a lot
they didn't chase him in here yeah
because he was just yeah that was uh
that's pretty intense that's a great
cliffhanger and um
what a wonderful build like this was
very incredibly cinematic absolutely and
very gooey and gross there's so many
interesting crazy blood games
it was like uh that that tongue bit was
really that was really off-putting
i love [ __ ] up [ __ ] do i i really love
like just messed up stuff
once in a while i see some gang i'm like
oh no that's not for that
yeah i don't like any part of imagining
what that is yeah
like i did not like that that is really
gross like if i if i watch this episode
again i'm not gonna probably gonna look
away
that and and and bom pal having just
like gallons of blood dumped into his
gaping house yeah like that like that's
fun i know that's funny like even like
he has to get back and then kick the
spear into him like i like that that's
fun you know yeah i just i i there's
certain body parts stuff that just like
i'm like oh yeah yeah yeah 100 pounds i
guess
you see tongue in these things so rarely
yeah yeah anything too much anything off
the beaten gore path like it's
especially around the head like like
tongue just face bits anything like that
well i think i'm a little traumatized
because um
my family wasn't the best at censoring
me one of the kids stuff
and one night there was some i to this
day i don't know what it was i don't
know what it was i was watching
but there was a it was like i must have
been i wanna say like first grade and
then there was some movie on and like my
family fell asleep to it or just played
and then some guy like kissed another
guy and then there's like a struggle
kiss and then he pulls out his and he
just bites off his tongue and then spits
it onto a plate
and you gotta imagine you're like a
little boy
i'm like no i was not expecting it
i don't expect this from any movie it's
disturbing now to be like
you're a little kid yeah i think like
anything with that is like no no no i i
don't like that yeah that's like the
nose scene in in in batman returns but
worse
yeah i know man right now now i'm gonna
have to look that scene up i haven't
seen the tunnel the tunnel
who traumatized myself
that was uh that was great
that was really exciting and um really
well done and soby didn't do everything
this episode toby barely did anything ah
she just oh she did was that's screaming
yeah that's what you think it is i think
it is and hey i did the rope thing and
anybody who ties gets tied up has to do
friction cut the rope
is there mythbusters about that there's
got to be a mythbusters about that
yeah this was uh this is this is awesome
it it's nice when it like the the show
rewards you with like paying it off of
being patient with the you know
you know actual like character
development
yeah
yeah because that's the the plot's the
point is that if we were being sarcastic
obviously because like the point is that
this
none of this action hits home unless
unless all that other plus all the other
stuff was happening to get to this point
of life change finally here [ __ ] finally
don't take our moment for money we just
started playing rock music over
everything don't take it away from us
let us have this
all right guys thank you so much for
being here make sure to check out our
reaction in the finale we'll see you
guys soon
[Music]